angela merkel est à moscou pour deux
jours c'est la dernière visite de la
chancelière allemande en russie avant de
quitter le pouvoir dans un peu plus d'un
moins de nombreux sujets ont été abordés
par les deux chefs d'état notamment la
situation en afghanistan à la
coopération entre les deux pays mais
aussi l'avenir de l'opposant politique
russe alexeï navalni on voit tout cela
avec notre correspondante à moscou vera
goffman
syrie libye ukraine biélorussie nombre
de sujets ont été abordés lors des
pourparlers entre vladimir poutine et
angela merkel mais qu'ont prévu la
situation en afghanistan a été au coeur
des discussions selon vladimir poutine
il faut surtout empêcher l'effondrement
du pays et ne pas laisser les
terroristes sans filtre et dans les pays
limitrophes je propose d'écouter on a vu
que le mouvement des talibans contrôlent
quasiment la totalité du territoire y
compris la capitale et compte tenu de
ces faits il faut analyser et étudier
les possibilités d'éviter un
effondrement de l'état afghan
et éviter en même temps
les jeux venant de l'extérieur pouvant
se dérouler sur le pays notamment en
cherchant à imposer la démocratie
selon des principes qui ne correspondent
pas aux réalités aux traditions
religieuses politiques et ethniques du
pays
pour angela merkel les pourparlers ont
été constructifs la chancelière
allemande a affirmé avoir exigé la
libération de l'opposant russe alexeï
navalni quant au président russe ella
souligné que navalni n'était pas
condamné pour son activité politique
mais pour des violations criminelles
elle a également appelé à respecter la
décision du tribunal russe écoutez nous
savons qu'il ya une situation assez
désagréable autour de l'excès navalni
il a été condamné il se retrouve en
prison suite à la décision du tribunal
qui avec
concert européen
de droits de l'homme est une chose
inadmissible
donc et j'ai exprimé mon opinion là
dessus et je réclame la libération d'al
excès navalni j'ai souligné que nous
allons suivre avec attention cette
affaire dans l'avenir en ce qui concerne
la personne dont vous avez parlé il n'a
pas été condamné pour son activité
politique mais pour des infractions des
actes criminels à l'égard de partenaires
étrangers
en ce qui concerne son activité
politique
je pense que personne ne doit se cacher
derrière des arts et des activités
politiques pour mener une activité qui
est criminel passer au second plan à
cause de la situation en afghanistan le
gazoduc nord stream ii était tout de
même évoqué par les deux dirigeants
l'admirent poutine affirmé qu'il ne
s'agissait pas d'un projet politique
quant à angela merkel est là souligné
que le nord stream 2 n'était pas un
projet russo allemand mais un projet
européen écoutez nous avons également
évoqué le sujet du nord stream de ce
n'est pas un projet bilatéral entre la
russie et l'allemagne mais c'est un
projet qui relève d'un caractère
européen parce qu'il réunit les
entreprises les autres pays également
madame la chancelière a toujours posé la
question de la poursuite du transit via
le territoire de l'ukraine même après
l'achèvement
l'expiration du contrat sur ce sujet
aujourd'hui cette question a été abordée
encore une fois pas la chancelière
aujourd'hui est gelée assuré que nous
respecterons toutes nos obligations en
matière de transit même une fois qu'elle
aura quitté son poste de chancelière la
russie va honorer tous ses engagements
nous le font et nous le faisons et nous
le ferons mais pourparlers ont duré
presque trois heures au lieu de deux
heures initialement prévues je rappelle
qu'il s'agit de la dernière ville
d'angela merkel en russie en qualité de
chancelière après 16 ans au pouvoir